All right, hello and welcome, everyone.
This is act int OrgStream number 3.1.
It's November 3, 2022. Our guest
of honor is Bijan Khezri, and we're really
looking forward today to talking about
the free energy principle, active
inference, and your experience and
recent work. However, for today,
you've requested that I set the stage
with a little bit of context on some of
the history and development of the
active reference distribution and by way
of doing so, set us up for a
serendipitous collision in our paths,
encoding around applied variational,
active inference, and the free energy
principle. So I connected
with the co founders of the active
inference Institute, then the active
Inference Lab, which is what it was
called until about June 2022 this year.
And we connected after hearing Karl
Friston speak with Lex Friedman and got
excited around some of the opportunities
around this developing framework of
active inference and the free energy
principle, the potential that a unifying
framework could help us understand
perception recognition model action
across different kinds of complex and
nested systems and then specifically
applying those models in the context of
especially remote teams and
organizations. And that resulted in our
2020 work active Inference and Behavior
Engineering for teams, which
additionally added in some systems
engineering perspectives especially
related to ontology lifecycle
perspective, continuous delivery,
continuous interactions, and so on,
also drawing from an open science and
open source background. And since then,
we've been on a journey, we've been
learning and applying active inference,
and our structure has developed.
Today we're the active reference
distribution and we're working on some
novelty formalizations of our
organizational structure and all these
other important aspects of successful,
which is to say surviving organizations
and organisms. And that's what led us
to find your work and immediately
resonate with it as some of the finest
contemporary examples of experience
guided and shaped and situation
tested cases of organizational active
inference. So that is how we came to be
excited about this area and use the
terms every day and use the ideas and
their relationships in our strategy and
to come across to work and see it as
salient.
BIJAN KHEZRI: Good. Thank you, Daniel. Well, first of
all, thank you very much for inviting me
on this live chat. I've been obviously
familiar with the active interference
institute. I think it was through the
theoretical neurobiology group of wisdom
that I got signed up to your newsletter.
And I was really intrigued by really
the diversity of activities of media
products you're generating in order to
advance the case actually for the active
reference trajectory.
When you want to ask actually, is there
any support from a governance point of
view that's really when we started
actually engaging, because I always feel
that in the area, in particular not for
profit, I like to pay my debts and
support it. Now, I do think that
actually you're doing an increase job.
It's clearly still at a very early
stage, which is actually equally true
for the active interference movement in
the respective sciences. So maybe
for those who are in the audience, not
too familiar actually with what really
active inference is about.
It's really very philosophy and very
scientific at the same time. Actually,
there's a mathematical framework
underlying it which has been applied
actually in machine learning and
actually in Karl Tristan's work, which
is the neuroimaging work. So it
is not just a philosophy concept,
but it is actually something which has
been applied in hard science and based
on mathematical formulas. But when
you really move away from the
mathematical model and you move more to
a philosophical model, then actually a
much more general audience starts
understanding that actually active
inference is maybe the only way
to engage with the world, which is
increasingly discontinuous and very
distributed. And I
will briefly just say my own path of
how I came across actually into the
concept. And then maybe a more general
audience, beyond actually neuroscience,
machine learning and biology will start
understanding how relevant the concept
of active inference is, of how you build
actually your own world model to
navigate. And in the world of business,
where I'm from, how to actually allocate
resources in very I
call it continuum environments, I don't
like the word uncertainty because
uncertainty is a very subjective
concept. And Zannone saying that the
world is uncertain is more reflection
and admission of the very limitations of
the world model they have. And that's
really where active inference comes in.
So my view and my origin actually of
engaging with the active inference
concept came through looking at
corporate governance, looking at the
challenges, actually thought leading
organizations in engaging with the
world, which is, as they say,
very difficult to predict. And we look
at an inferential model, and when you
look specifically at the active
interference model, you start looking at
a system, which is actually a wonderful
system to look at, and all of a sudden
you can break actually a world which
seems to be quite difficult to predict
into something you can navigate,
actually in a wonderfully simple way.
And the way I look at it is really at
the following six components.
And I deliberately did not prepare
presentation A because I'm very bad with
representations to prepare them in the
first place. But I do understand for the
audience, sometimes it's much easier to
have it visualized in front of you. So
I'm trying really in simple ways to
visualize for you in your head. And you
may close your eyes as you do this, or
how you build the active interference
framework really bottom up in a very
simplistic way,
reflective. There's really two things
one has to always look at when you look
at the world. There's things you know
and there area things you don't know.
The second dimension is there are things
you control and there are other things
you don't control. And this is
a fact. There area many things we don't
know. This is the unknown which is
outside and sometimes inside even.
And there's many things which are beyond
our control. And now we have to build
bottomup a model which allows us
actually to navigate through this. And
the way the active interference model is
built is that you're looking at four
states and I will go into the states in
a second. You look at actually a wall
or a blanket which is actually learning
the known from the unknown which is
really the inner world from the outer
world. And you have a very simple first
order principle which has no purpose in
its own right other than orchestrating
this whole thing. And orchestrating
means we have only one objective,
we area pursuing and effectively in
social life you can actually bring down
our ultimate objective as we navigate
and we deal with uncertainty and
unpredictability is we want to minimize
surprise. And minimize surprise
mathematically is really a matter of
minimizing the error of
probability state space. I'm coming now
to the states. We have an active state
which is really our actions. Our actions
actually determine our sensory state
which is what we sense. We have an outer
world, the external state and we have an
internal states. The inner state is
really our resources in the theorem
context you may say actually what are
the firm resources? Now you look at
these four states, active sensory,
internal and external, very simple.
And the internal and the external are
really related to a wall which we call
the Markov blanket. And the Markov
blanket does really manage of
how we try and minimize our
probability estimates through constantly
updating our beliefs.
And we do this by trying to minimize at
every juncture in a very generative way
free energy and information theory is
really just a measure of error. So once
you see this, you see in a very very
simple way to distill this model now
that actually you need to act to create
your own sensations which allow you
to actually continuously update your
beliefs, what beliefs you have about
actually the unknown world. And this is
a very generative model. The generative
model itself doesn't encode anything but
the generative model is just putting
into a very dynamic relationship how
these four states are being governed.
And this is really kind of the theory
part of it when you look at it from a
material and from a practical point of
view you can very quickly see for a firm
that actually there shouldn't be any
uncertainty. What you need is you need
to engage in a very active way with the
world, with a very clearly defined
prediction model which generates
predictions and your actions
continuously actually update those
predictions and eventually you will
minimize actually the error. So what
that means concrete, what does it mean
precisely in the concept of
strategy? When you look at organizations
and that's obviously the field where I
have a lot of experience as a board
member, as a CEO.
Traditionally the strategy process,
and this is how they teach it at
management schools, is very environment
driven. The objective is to say you've
got to analyze the environment in order
to define what your strategy is. And the
active inference view is that this is
wrong. Actually your strategy is
really interpretation driven, which is
effectively by your predictions. It's
driven. And then you look for the data
points in the environment to either
confirm, refute, fine tune actually your
prediction and eventually, if you're not
right with your prediction errors, dot
two update your prediction model. So
what does that mean precisely? When you
look now at state there's only one thing
as a hyperpria talking in Bayesian
terms, there's only one thing which is
important and that's what's your
purpose? What's the purpose of the
company? And if the purpose of the
company is clear, the top, which is
the board, the executive leadership,
start generating prediction models of
how to best realize this purpose and
then it's really for the rest of the
organization in a very iterative model
to feedback bottom up the data points
and then actually it becomes a very
continuum process. Hence the title of my
book is also Continuous Transformation.
It's a process which is becoming
integral to the DNA of actually being in
the game, competing in the marketplace.
Strategy is no longer about topdown
content prescriptions. It's really a
topdown bottom up, continuous,
interactive, generative process. So if
you look at it, active inference is,
normatively speaking, really of course a
theory, but it really is a process
model. It's a process model of how to
minimize surprise and uncertainty
in a very complex world. And when you
look at biological systems, they have
done this in wonderful, wonderfully
selforganizing mechanisms. And I think
the challenge for the business world is
to reintroduce and bring to life to
selforganizing mechanisms. And the
active inference framework is such a
framework. And when you look at my work
in business administration, I've adapted
the active reference trajectory to how
to make it work and what it means in the
context of business organizations.
Wow, there's a lot there.
Active inference as a process model for
minimizing uncertainty in complex worlds
and a broader theme of using cutting
edge developments as evidenced by your
books bibliography, everything from
cognitive science of individuals to
organizational studies and quantum
mechanics, all these interesting areas
and also really awesome how you framed
some of the 0th principles or the
commitments that this first principles
framework makes. Like the separation
between things you know and things you
don't know, things you control and
things you don't control and of course
all the nuancing that can happen like a
continuum of controllability. So I
guess to put it back into the embodied
court, what do these topdown
expectations and bottomup signals look
like? Are those emails or what are those
actual operational details of this
type of organizational design?
Well, first of all,
it's a very good question because it's
kind of funny also when I did the
empirical work supporting actually my
theoretical work, it's really funny how
companies try to make the case
that they operate actually in this way.
Now, obviously in today's world you have
many technology based tools which allow
companies to engage in
very attributes environment in real
time. Slack for example, is one of those
where you create actually you connect,
actually pop down bottom and you engage
the bottom in a very interesting way.
As part of my dissertation and the
book research, I went into the question
you asked right now a little bit deeper
and starting to understand how
companies in an age where there is
many technology tools for massive
agreement, how they can use actually
the button in order to refine theory,
action, prediction. When you look
at the early days,
it was kind of all about collective
intelligence, collective collaboration,
how you bring sometimes it was more on a
project level. At IMD in Los
Angeles, this two researchers, they have
created actually a active inference
undertaking which was really meant to be
able to define the
questions in the first place, which
actually the base should respond to. So
what are the relevant questions?
Because obviously by asking a reliving
question you frame something and you
frame a pass. How can you even
neutralize this by empowering the base
to generate actually what are the right
questions to do?
Cell I shouldn't say there is a big
movement, but there has been a movement
and there has been a lot of research on
it and actually they're very big
companies from Red Bull to diamonds to
many big companies which have applied
it, which is called open strategy. And
the idea of the open strategy framework
was that actually the strategic issues
which are relevant for the company to
compete in the law firm should be
generated through the base, the employee
base of the company. And there were
obviously various technology tools which
were deployed in order to do this.
I think all these things had very mixed
results because the question is can you
really open to such a big forum?
Sense states questions so it
has been controversial within the
perspective companies, some companies
had really some good input but on the
other hand, it raises also expectations
in the employee base and if it's too
project driven rather than actually
really integral to the DNA on a
continuous basis, usually these things,
they fail. One idea I
like a lot, having said this, I must
admit I haven't implemented it in my own
company. I like the idea when you think
in a company the very top is the board
of directors and you could see beneath
it obviously the executive leadership
team. I like very much the idea of
creating shadow boards with
younger employees and who face the same
agenda the top board is facing and you
look at what kind of discussion points,
what kind of agenda items, what kind of
action representations come from the
base. And I think if you do this in a
structured way, it's a great way of
incentivizing actually the high
potential in the company. But also I
think what you're doing is actually you
really engage the base to
think strategically and to challenge the
top with exactly the very same topic
they're facing. And by the way, that may
generate actually future agenda points
as well. So I think the idea has to
be definitely to open up, there's no
question about it, but probably to do it
in a more focused way. That's why I
think it's shadowboard is a really great
thing. I just communicated on
this on LinkedIn this week. But I
think what is much more important and
this is what the active reference
trajectory and that's why I believe the
active inference institute is doing an
invaluable job by starting
to understand actually what active
interference and practical implication
really means. We have to change
fundamentally the way we communicate.
And the biggest problem you have in
organizations, any organization, is the
communication. And whenever I look at
the top down, bottom up Bayesian brain,
you obviously understanding that an
organization will never, ever be able to
work that efficiently connecting the
topic and the bottom nervous system in a
way to operate, but we have
to approximate it. And all of a sudden,
when you start understanding the
Bayesian brain in neuroscience and
you apply the active reference
trajectory to social organism mandrake
artifacts, you all of a sudden start
understanding how much friction there
is. And myself, as a business leader,
CEO, chairman, I'm only dedicated
to one thing, and from theorem,
everything flows brilliantly. And I
think this is the evidence of great and
future oriented leadership in this
continuous market environment, is take
the friction out between the bottom and
the top and there's far too much
friction in all the organizations. And
that leads many times to the fact that
you have very variable intelligence.
All the intelligence in an organization
is at the very bottom. There is no
intelligence at the top, and the top is
only as intelligent as the bottom is.
So a very key, almost categoric
imperative for firm performance,
for a company's performance and
competitiveness is really how
do you bring the bottom up intelligence
all the way up. And only on that basis
will you develop smart prediction
models, great predictions, and bring
them back to the bottom to challenge
them and evolve them. It's a generative
process. So I think what we need to
finally say goodbye to, and this is the
key message of the active inference
framework, we need to say goodbye that
you can drive competitiveness,
a future strategy by concept
prescriptions, put it in the right
process, define a very clear purpose and
follow a first order principle to
orchestrate everything, which is free
energy minimization. As I said before,
in information theoretical terms, free
energy is nothing but a measure of
error. So all we want to do is measure
the error between our predictions and
the present states when noise. And once
you follow that process, you set free in
organization. I gave an example in my
book which is about actually when you do
the budget and right now, again in
October, November is the budgeting
period for companies to set the budget
for the next year. Again, you're facing
knowns and unknowns, you're facing
issues you control, there's other issues
you don't control. And the management
team is challenged to put a budget
together. The only way they can
deal with the unknown is by defining
actions they believe can generate the
right stimuli to actually update their
prediction model in a continuum way. So
when I look at the budget, of course I
have to look at the numbers, but I'm
reality not interested in the numbers.
I'm looking at the underlying
assumptions and the hypotheses and I'm
looking at the action model and the
precise actions the management team
looking to undertake to optimize
actually action prediction and to gain
more and more control and to turn the
unknown into the known. And that's all
it is about as we navigate through this
world, be more in control, know more
and have less of the unknown. And that's
a continuum process. And I think if
anyone gets it and gets the active
interference framework, then I think
we will no longer talk about uncertainty
in business in the way we talk about it
today. We are really talking more about
model uncertainty, but there is no such
thing as uncertainty in an objective
way.
Lot to add there, but really
interesting how you highlighted the
necessity of appropriate communications
and pointed to communications as one of
the biggest area of challenge and
uncoincidentally. Also one of the areas
for which for digital organizations,
the affordance area, active states and
the wiring diagram of the organization,
so to speak, the effective and the
functional causal edges, to use some
analogies from neuroimaging, those edges
are composable, often digitally and
increasingly with augmented and digital
collaborators. And so that space
of wiring is vast.
It's faster than building a physical
building or object because it can exist
with many different counterfactuals and
in kind of imagined spaces. So how do we
go from this insight and
maybe even some imperatives or
heuristics like to reduce the friction
between the bottom and the top, as you
described, towards a given or particular
organizational structure in a certain
concept. There have
been models. I think one company,
Zappos, has been doing this more
in a holographic way, trying to
really,
the way I say it, in very simplistic
terms, looking at organizational models
and organizational forms. If we do
agree as a working assumption that the
world is discontinuous and attributes,
then I do believe that organizational
structures need to be much more
distributed and much less centralized.
And I think we need to break up
companies and bring them into smaller
units and empower them and
they will be much more performing,
because what we're doing is we area
minimizing or optimizing in a certain
way the pathway between bottomup
intelligence and stimuli, going actually
to top action prediction. And that
should be the ultimate objective. How
can we minimize the friction? And
sometimes the friction is really a
function of how we simplify organization
and forms of organizing. What's very
interesting when you look there is kind
of and it comes really from prehistoric
times before even language appeared,
when actually people communicated in
forms of touching each other, that the
maximum number of a community
is 150. That's where you can distinguish
switch touches in certain ways. And
that's kind of a magic number, which has
been actually, I guess these are the
very origins, as some researchers
in the language field have informed me.
But I think it's funny to see that
there's a number of companies which look
at the 150 to 200 as the magic number.
And that's when actually an
organizational entity should be no
bigger. And if a company has 50 Zebra
employees, then it should be really in
much smaller units and empower them.
And I think that's what I'm doing. My
company's obviously not that big, but in
my company, I have four companies which
are quite distinct companies, but I
think that's the strength, because
theory form one unity, but they remain
very distinct. And I can see that they
are much more performing if they were
just business units as part of a bigger
thing. So they have very autonomous and
very respective leadership structures.
And I do believe to your point,
looking at the form of organization is
very critical. And I do think, having
said so, there have been many
researchers before who have been looking
at neuroscience, the structure of the
brain, transferring it actually to
organizational science, and it has been
certainly true for biology. But I'm
always fascinated looking into biology,
how our first
of all, how perception is very
spaceyspecific and how we
have a tendency to generalize and
obviously make it very human centric the
world. And once we get to the point that
we start understanding that the world is
not human centric, then actually
I think we will be much more open to be
enriched by the insights and
the inspiration the biological world can
give us and to actually become aware of
the very limitations we have and how we
can actually navigate with uncertainty.
And there the active reference
trajectory will come in. And I think the
problem we have as a human species is
that we are the only species
which has this understanding power of
learning, but we have so many
limitations which are very severe and
kind of we area empowered on the one
side with learning, but we are
completely handicapped on the other
side. We can't see electric magnetic
waves. So there's many interesting
theories and some of them I
really like that our reflective or if
you look at the very sense of evolution
has never been about seeing the truth as
bit is our existence and our
epistemic for raging and exploration is
not about approximating truth.
Actually most of the time we do ignore
the truth. It's all about fitness
payoffs because we want to survive and
we want to procreate and it's all about
that and that drives our behavior and
you start not looking at things the way
theory are as much as actually our
engagement we see a desktop. But behind
the desktop are pixels in many different
things which actually create our
perception but what we're seeing is
definitely not the truth. So I think
unless we get to the point where we say
goodbye very classical notion and that's
why I bring also my book the Relation
and the Juxtaposition between classical
physics and quantum physics. We have to
move to quantum physics and we need to
actually start understanding the world
does not operate according to classical
laws. It really operating point to
quantum law. And once you start doing
it, I think you have to embrace
our evidence but the way we control
not control the known and the unknown in
a completely new way. And my
contribution in the active inference
framework is really to say this is
something which is immensely valuable to
redefining what strategy dean in the
business world I know we're at the very
beginning. That's why I'm sure the
audience engaging with us today is a
very small audience and I have to say,
as you could see also with my
theoretical introduction to the active
interference framework, it is so
abstract for many people, for us it's so
natural and we see the mathematical
formulas behind it and we see the
consistency. But forming
a book, writing a book even for the
business community makes it almost a
book nobody can read and nobody can
understand. But I'm absolutely of the
conviction that this book, that the work
of the active reference distribution and
Karl Friston has been our great source
of inclination for all of this is
setting free a movement. And I'm
absolutely convinced it's just a matter
of time that this become in a very
significant way mainstream.
Wow. Well a lot you add there the
recurrent mention of the distributed
systems and state in distributed systems
reminds me of my earlier graduate school
work on foraging decision making in ants
where no single nest mate knows how
many seeds the colony has, how many
seeds there are out there, what's the
humidity, what's the water loss rate,
none of the relevant information. And
yet it embodies through behavior,
development, evolution, biology, it
embodies a solution to the regularities
of that niche which includes like
abiotic challenges, antibiotic
challenges and then you've connected to
epistemic foraging which is what we use
to describe when actions are
understanding with the imperative
primarily of reducing uncertainty and
gaining information. And the free energy
imperative has a dual epistemic and
pragmatic component. So under conditions
of high certainty epistemically, the
pragmatic component can be dialed in.
In the special case converging on
utility learning. And then in scenarios
with a flatter landscape where there's
less of a sharpness or need for
pragmatism, there's an exploration
landscape where the epistemic value and
the novelty can be generated. And so
there's just so much there in thinking
about distributed systems in biology and
in organizations which after all are
biological too. So what
are your closing thoughts?
No, I think we
covered certainly for an audience to get
an insight of active interference
framework, applying it. I like very much
your last contribution because I'm
fascinated by the work you have done
with ants and even the brains of ants.
I mean, you're going down to a level
which is almost quantum in a certain way
and I
can only reiterate that I reality
would love to see this interview is my
contribution also of really firmly
establishing the Active Interference
Institute as a great force for a
whole new way of being inspired by
biology neuroscience to
embrace the world with a completely
different mindset. And I think the world
is today in a state where it's
so obvious that actually we area
overwhelmed, whether it's from a
geopolitical point of view, whether it's
from an economic point of view and
eventually from a psychological point of
view because the dynamics have become
very complex. Why? Because technology
has empowered every person to have
actually a beyond imaginable impact on
the whole one individual potentially to
be I don't like the word disruptive,
but to generate discontinuities. And
that makes it actually increasingly
difficult to construct an algorithm with
not only what variables are part of it,
but how do the variables relate and what
is their respective waiting in the
algorithm to start developing
actually a way moving forward. And I
am of the conviction and I see it
reading the mainstream newspapers, I
don't really read the newspapers, but
looking at actually through the voices
which come through from the leaders in
various forums, they area overwhelmed
and they have reached the very
limitations of defining
articulating communication, their very
world model. I think actually they
haven't got a world model any longer and
because they haven't got it, they are
control error, uncertainty and
unpredictability. And I do believe that
the time is so ripe for actually
bringing more awareness to the fact of
how we have to work on our model
forward, model, reality models,
whatever you want to call it, and more
importantly, what processes should be in
place to actually update those models
and make them better and better going
forward. And I can start and I have to
say they're wonderful examples which
have really and I want to give this as a
closing remark, as an example. When you
look at the gain world. I'm obviously
coming from the gaming world. As an
entrepreneur you have traditionally
reward functions in a game. So let's
take a very simple shooter game. In a
shooter game, the agent is rewarded who
shoots most of the planes and eventually
is the winner. Let's assume that's the
logic of the game. When you look at the
free energy minimization powered agent
he has or she has no cue about
what the reward function of the game is
zero. All the agent does is the agent
starts playing the game and chaos only
one first order principle which is to
minimize surprise. So eventually the
agent starts learning in order to
survive, which is the hyper prior you
need to behave in a certain way in order
not to get shot and you have to engage
in certain behavioral traits. So now you
have two agents in one game. The game is
a shooter game, there is a reward
function powered agent and there
is a free energy or surprise
minimization powered agent. The free
energy agent will always win, always
because it takes a little bit longer to
train it. But eventually you don't
need to know the reward function and the
reward functions are outdated by the
time you communicate them and companies
need to understand this. Liberalize
yourself, free yourself actually from
all that friction you area creating with
PowerPoint presentations, with top down
communication which fossilize the
mindset and the intelligence which is at
the bottom of the company. Just put a
selforganizing process governed by the
free energy principle in place and once
you have a clearly defined purpose which
is timeless, you create your prediction
models and the journey can start and
you will see there's no more any such
thing as uncertainty. It's only a way of
how uncertainty minimizing your
models are. And that's the only thing.
Amazing. Well for those who are
listening all the way we expect and
reference trajectory, you will get
involved or otherwise allocate your
regime of attention to active inference
and the active inference institute and
hopefully participate in some way.
Thanks for this awesome conversation.
We really have so much to learn from
each other and from our niche and from
the unknown unknowns and from the bottom
and from all around. So awesome
and until next time, thank you. Thank
you Daniel, much appreciate it.